Okay, Mavis L. from
Rancho Cucamonga writes,
"Amy, why do you talk
about your pussy so much?
"Are you scared we don't
believe you have one?
We get it.
You're disgusting."
I have to say
that I have no idea
what that is
in reference to.
(snickering)
Uh, you know.
No idea.
You know.
We all know.
I have literally
never in my life
said that word before, so...
What did you just say?!
I said you're delusional!
What did you just say?
Say it to my face!
I said "You're day-loo..."
(both shouting)
I said you're delusional!
You don't even know
what delusional means!
You don't know
what it means.
You don't know what
anything means!
I'm not delusional.
Yeah, you always
take her side!
No, you know what?
I can't, no.
(Kim)
Sit down.
Good, good, walk out
like you always do.
I'm not, I'm not.
Walk out like
you always do.
No, because you know
why I'm not?!
Because, because
you know why I'm not!
And what you wrote
is very hurtful to me.
I didn't say anything!
It's very hurtful to me!
Prove it!
I didn't say anything!
Sit back down, Amy.
Okay.
Come back.
Sit down, Kim.
Amy, are you seriously saying
that you've never
said the word "pussy"?
Andy, on my life... never!
Never have I ever said
that word on my life.
On my children's lives!
On my children's
children's lives.
Never have I said that word.
That's family, and you
don't do that to family.
Wait, are you saying
your pussy is family?
She knows what
I'm talking about.
Nobody knows what
you're talking about!
You know what
I'm talking about!
Nobody knows!
Nobody knows.
Okay, well, let's see what
everybody is talking about.
Take a look.
Close your eyes.
Okay.
Give me your hand.
Mm-hmm.
Guess where your finger
is right now.
My pussy.
My pussy tastes
like nothing.
'Cause I ate pussy
for breakfast.
I hope this kid's ready
to (bleep) a ton of pussy.
Pussies.
Pussy.
Pussy!
Stop talking out
of your pussy right now.
If my pussy had
a voice,
it would sound
like Terry Gross
with just a mouthful
of crackers.
My character has a pussy.
Pussies.
Can you not say... pussy?
♪ My pussy's (bleep) magic ♪
With a pussy on it.
I don't see what's
so hard about...
just saying "vagina."
Will this fix
my garbage pussy?
Are you that girl
from the television
who talks about
her pussy all the time?
Yes!
Kinda seems like
you say "pussy" a lot, Amy.
Thank you.
I see why
you would think that.
And I, I want to
"sincereiously" apologize
to my fans if that's what
they thought I was saying.
But I have grown a lot.
This has been a journey
with me and God.
And everyone at the precinct
near my house.
And I know what's in my heart.
And it is my pussy.
Okay, I mean-- and, and I do,
I do wanna say this.
I do wanna say this
about Amy, okay?
I know that we have had
our differences.
Mm-hmm.
And I know that she knows
that I do hate her.
Okay, but she also does
say that, like,
she has a good heart.
Okay, and she says
she has a good heart
and family is family.
Thank you
for saying that.
Family is family.
(sobbing)
(Andy)
That's nice,
that was kind of you.
We'll be right back.